in Halloween ends we see a lorish road
who is trying to find some normalcy in
her life she needs to overcome her past
by celebrating Halloween like a normal
person rather than going to war with
Michael Myers to do this we see her
carve a pumpkin a holiday activity she
took part in when we first met her in
1978. back then it was her Tommy and
Lindsay and this time she's with Allison
and Lindsay later on we get a look at
the finished product and it looks just
like the one she carved all those years
ago I guess her style hasn't changed
much over the last 44 years we also see
this in her attire in the original film
she had this long brim hat in her room
which she held on to until 2018 where it
would have been destroyed in the fire
ironically when she Burns her pie in
Halloween ends you can spot a
replacement hat near the front door
another trait from Lori's past that
persevered is the way she Twirls her
hair when she thinks about her Crush in
the original she did this while
discussing the target of her High School
affection and Ben tramer and now 44
years later she reacts similarly when
running into Frank Hawkins at the
supermarket maybe you didn't notice
those details when you first watched the
movie so in this video I'm gonna go over
everything you might have missed in
Halloween ends from Tiny details and
newspapers to the broader meaning of the
entire film stick around to the end of
this video this video is brought to you
by established titles
welcome to things you missed we once
again find ourselves at the end of the
line here on the Halloween Express I'm
glad to see one of these timelines
actually have a definitive ending for
once you could argue that Rob Zombie's
timeline was definitive but Halloween
ends leaves little to the imagination no
matter what you think about this movie
you have to give the filmmaker David
Gordon green and writer Danny McBride
credit for finishing what they started
every good story has a beginning middle
and end even when it does include a
Timeless character like Michael Myers
this story has come to an end but like
every great Legend it can always be
reimagined for future Generations while
the story may have come to an end there
are still many more things you might
have missed to slash our way through so
let's slide into our next one
the opening song of the movie midnight
monsters hop has lyrics that describe a
concert with many classic Halloween
monsters like Dracula the Invisible Man
Frankenstein and the mummy who started
as Pop Culture icons like Michael Myers
but are now Eternal urban legends these
are classic Universal monsters and to
this Trilogy of Halloween films was made
by Universal's blumhouse so it's almost
as if Michael Myers is following in
their footsteps the opening titles are
done in the same style as the titles
from Halloween 3 season of The Witch the
black sheep of the franchise this made
me realize that there's a pattern
Halloween 2018 was the first Blum House
Halloween and it mimics the titles from
Halloween one Halloween kills was the
second Bloom house Halloween and its
titles resemble Rick's Halloween 2. ends
is the third of the blumhouse trilogy so
it took on the style of Halloween 3. the
opening scene shows our new character
Corey babysitting for this kid named
Jeremy as the parents are about to leave
I noticed the mom holding a small Jerome
it reminded me of the scene from
Halloween kills where Michael destroys
Sandra's drone just before attacking her
and her husband but I don't think this
drone is a callback because shortly
after we see that Jeremy prefers playing
with paper airplanes he has access to
the newest technology but still chooses
the old classic we also see Lori playing
with the paper plane when she confronts
Corey later on it seems symbolic for a
movie with two main antagonists the old
classic Michael Myers and the newcomer
Corey Cunningham Corey just ends up
modeling himself after Michael so once
again the original Can't speed beads
it's Halloween
we're gonna have a good time tonight
thank God he didn't say Everyone's
entitled to one good scare Corey and
Jeremy end up watching John Carpenter's
The Thing which is a remake of the thing
from another world which Lori and Tommy
watched in the original it's significant
that they chose John Carpenter's The
Thing because as you may know John
Carpenter directed the original
Halloween and Halloween ends honors more
of his filmography in particular ends is
more of a remake of John Carpenter's
1983 film Christine than it is a
Halloween sequel in Halloween ends we
follow a character named Corey
Cunningham who is an obvious homage to
Christine's main character Arnie
Cunningham spoilers for Christine until
the end of this chapter Arnie starts off
as kind of a loser until he buys this
old car named Christine and decides to
fix it up as he does so he becomes
cooler and starts to stand up for
himself against his bullies and his
overly strict parents the car is
actually a supernatural entity with the
ability to repair herself and go after
Arnie's enemies on her own owning this
car changes his personality and gross
his ego but it goes too far and Arnie
becomes a villain willing to attack
those that care about him when they show
concern about the evil car in Halloween
ends Corey starts as an outcast because
of his babysitting accident like Arnie
he gets his glasses broken by High
School bullies and his life is dominated
by his strict mother but his luck starts
to change when he receives this
motorcycle from his stepdad with the
promise that he can fix it up Corey
works at Prevost Auto which looks like a
smaller version of Darnell's garage
where Arnie fixes up Christine I found
it interesting that Prevo Otto was
established in 1963. the same year that
Michael seemingly became evil and killed
his older sister it's like there's this
parallel between Michael and the
junkyard which is appropriate because
Corey's motorcycle is not the Christine
of this movie Michael Myers is Christine
let me explain Corey is always said to
be a good kid who had a bad break even
the father of the boy that he killed
admits that Jeremy's death was an
accident but something else later seemed
to send Corey down a dark path it is
true that this happens right after he
gets the motorcycle but it's around the
same time that he first encounters
Michael Myers like Christine Michael
Myers is in a sad State when we first
encounter him and Corey like Arnie
develops a strange fascination with him
Christine seems to have Arnie under some
kind of Trance as soon as he lays eyes
on her and Halloween ends features this
moment where Corey and Michael first
make eye contact and something
non-verbal seems to be passed between
them Christine seems to regain her power
after Arnie spends countless hours
fixing her up in the garage and in
Michael's case he seems to regain power
after Corey brings him a new victim the
way Christine puts herself back together
even kind of resembles the way that
Michael visually regains his Mojo after
taking a life in each film The
Cunningham character gains more
confidence and Swagger after their first
encounter with the supernatural they
both ditched their glasses because not
wearing glasses instantly makes you more
attractive in a movie hey man no glasses
you're looking good Arnie Cunningham
starts dating the most coveted girl in
the school and Christine tries to kill
her by locking her in the cabin when she
starts choking Corey Cunningham meets
and begins to date Allison who is
similarly an enemy of Michael Arnie
stops listening to his mother and stops
respecting his parents and Corey does
the same finally Christine is totaled by
bullies so after getting fixed she goes
after them and hunts them down each time
we see the bright headlights blasting
them before Christine chases them down
and kills them in Halloween the bullies
try to ruin Corey's motorcycle and he
confronts them by targeting them in the
bright lights of the tow truck before
running them down it's definitely paying
tributes that I iconic Christine shot in
the end Arnie's best friend and
ex-girlfriend battle and defeat
Christine in the auto garage where she's
compacted and dumped in the junkyard but
they're unable to save Arnie while on
Halloween ends Lori and Allison also
defeat Michael and bring him to the
junkyard to be destroyed but they are
unable to save Corey there's also a
cameo in this movie from Diana Prince
who is known in the horror Community as
the co-host of the last Drive-In one of
Christine's iconic scenes takes place at
a drive-in movie there was talk earlier
this year of Christine getting its own
blumhouse remake which Stephen King the
author of the novel was not thrilled
about so I'm hoping Halloween ends is
instead of that because I think I prefer
this weird amalgamation of two John
Carpenter movies to a remake of a movie
that still holds up and doesn't really
need to be remade plus Stephen King
liked it seriously Blum House quit while
you're ahead after meeting Corey we move
on to Lori who has a collection of
newspapers pinned to our wall which
contain a few things you might have
missed
[Music]
established titles is a fun and novel
way to preserve the natural Woodlands of
Scotland while helping Global
reforestation efforts the project is
based on a historic Scottish custom
where landowners are referred to as
lairds or Lords and Ladies in English
you can buy a title pack ranging from as
much as 10 square feet to as little as
one square foot of land and with each
order they will plant a tree your tree
and work with global Charities one tree
planted and trees for the future to
support Global reforestation efforts
which is what we need because the Earth
is really screwed right now you'll
receive a title with a unique plot
number on a private estate in edelston
Scotland and an official certificate
with a crash but the best part is I have
made arrangements with established
titles so that the first 200 people to
purchase the title with my link will be
placed effectively next to my plot
meaning that you can help cz's World
become a real physical place and
considering it will be all trees and no
cars it will be the greatest Kingdom of
all time you could officially include
the title Lord or lady on your credit
card plane tickets or dating profiles it
makes an amazing last minute gift
established titles is actually running a
massive early Black Friday sale right
now plus you can can use the code cz's
world and get an additional 10 off go to
establishtitles.comworld to get your
gifts now and help support the channel
[Music]
one thing Halloween ends does really
well is foreshadowing which makes it a
joy to watch for your second and third
viewing there are many covert clues
about Corey's transition to evil and
alignment with Michael Myers in my
Michael Myers Horror history episode I
talked all about how Michael seems to be
stuck in a childlike mindset because of
his trauma at six years old Corey seems
to have that same mindset which can be
seen in his beverage of choice in the
opening he's confronted with a choice
between chocolate milk and a beer and he
goes with chocolate milk then again at
the gas station he chooses milk and
refuses to buy beer for the kids
pressuring him in the parking lot beer
is obviously an adult beverage you have
to be 21 to drink it in the U.S while
milk is considered to be beneficial for
growing children but the lactase enzyme
responsible for digesting it goes away
in most adults I also noticed that
Corey's mom drinks milk with her
spaghetti and she definitely has some
weird issues another example of
foreshadowing can be seen in Corey's
actual Shadow as he heads up the stairs
it looks like the silhouette of Michael
Myers which we saw before in Halloween
6. as I mentioned Corey is a mechanic
and we see him in his work uniform early
on which happens to be the same costume
that Michael Myers wears he's also seen
using the blowtorch which he would later
weaponize against the leader of the
bullies Terry in a pretty awesome kill
When Corey and Allison hang out on the
rooftop of the radio station he claims
he's not interested in immortality and
drops down to the ground falling on his
back he appears to be hurt then sits up
in the same fashion that Michael always
sits up after a recharge period Cory's
death or at least his apparent death is
also foreshadowed during the dance party
scene he's laying on the dance floor for
some reason and Allison runs her hands
along his face and neck at the end when
Allison comes home to discover Corey's
self-inflicted injury she finds herself
in the same position outside of hints
about Corey there are also other aspects
of the movie that are set up the recap
at the beginning uses a shot from the
original Halloween of Lori attacking
Michael with her knitting needle most of
us have seen the original Halloween but
it's a nice touch to include that for
those who haven't because it foreshadows
the moment later in Halloween ends we
even see that she still knits so it
makes more sense when she finds the
needle and uses it as a weapon in the
final battle there are many aspects of
the final showdown that are set up
earlier on like the scene where Lori
Burns her pumpkin pie this shows us the
location of the fire extinguisher so
it's more more satisfying when she gets
it and uses it in the finale similarly
there's a scene where Allison leaves her
meal in the microwave for too long and
it explodes Lori later does this on
purpose as a loud noise that can
distract Michael
then when Lori tries to warn her
granddaughter about Corey she uses the
following words I'm not gonna let this
happen to you you'll have to believe me
which are the first words out of
Allison's mouth when she comes back to
save her grandmother I'm not gonna let
this happen to you and the last thing
I'm gonna point out as far as
foreshadowing is how they foreshadowed
Michael's death one of the first things
that we ever see at the junkyard is that
industrial Shredder it's very brief but
it's a nice setup it's shown again later
on but my favorite might be the butcher
at the grocery store
[Music]
is that a little clue that Michael is
eventually going to become ground beef
himself the procession scene right
before Michael's body is destroyed is a
great way to wrap up the trilogy because
it allows us to see many of the
characters who made it all the way
through like Sheriff Barker the
graveyard caretaker Sandra Larson and
the snarky kid Julian Morrissey each of
these characters appeared in all three
movies and survived till the end we even
see wccd make one last appearance nice
let's move on to the Easter eggs some
Halloween fans may remember the
Halloween novelization these books were
not canon but gave fans a little more
detail about their favorite Halloween
stories characters and lore the
novelization of the original Halloween
has details about what became of Judith
and Michael's parents after losing their
kids where they are given names for the
first time Donald Myers and Edith Myers
these names are referenced in Halloween
ends and an article pins to Lori strod's
wall titled 60 year old kills teen
sister in Halloween tragedy you can see
their names from the novelization are
now Canon there's also an obituary
section revealing the name of Linda's
mother Marilyn Van Der kloch this is
also a name taken from the novel
then again you might not want to trust
the newspaper this article titled Myers
Manhunt underway states that Michael had
27 victims in 2018. it's not entirely
clear who lived and who died but if you
tally up all of the victims from
Halloween 2018 and Halloween kills you
would get a number somewhere in the 50s
I like to think this article was written
before all the bodies had been
discovered but there's no excuse you can
make for this next part where it says
that in 1978 Michael killed five
teenagers with Lori Strode being the
only sole survivor this is just not true
Michael killed three teenagers that year
and Laurie was one of four survivors
alongside Tommy Lindsay and Dr Loomis
there's one more potential error here
where it says that Michael was last seen
at 45 Lampkin Lane in Haddonfield in my
Halloween kills episode I talked about
how the address of the Myers house is
709 Lampkin Lane with 45 Lampkin Lane
being mistake made in Rick's Halloween 2
which is not part of this timeline it is
possible though that there's a neighbor
who actually does live at 45 Lampkin
Lane who was the last one to spot
Michael maybe that's what this article
is talking about as long as we're taking
a closer look at these articles let's
look at this one Nightblade Landmark
destroy Nightblade was a working title
for Halloween 2018 and during the early
stages of production and the film was
made under the company name Nightblade
Holdings LLC Halloween kills followed
suit with the company name being
Nightblade 2 Holdings and ends was made
by Nightblade 3 Holdings but this
article was not the only instance of the
behind the scenes content being in these
scenes themselves this hobo is a cameo
by Christopher Nelson these special
effects makeup designer for the trilogy
you may remember I pointed out his other
cameo in Halloween 2018 where he played
a police officer Deborah Hill who
produced on the original Three Halloween
movies is sadly no longer a round to
make a cameo appearance but there is a
nurse character named Deb who seems to
be a tribute to her during the
production of the original Halloween she
was dating John Carpenter and the
character Deb is secretly dating the man
calling the shots at the clinic Dr
Mathis of course Deb's death is a direct
retread of a famous death from the
original movie throughout Halloween ends
Lori can be seen writing a book in order
to help her cope with the horrible
events that she's endured this is almost
certainly a nod to her fellow final girl
Sydney Prescott who has a similar coping
strategy in screen form yes that is the
correct pronunciation based on the
spelling scree for the relationship
between Halloween and scream began in
1996 in the original scream where
Halloween was shown to guests at a party
in 1998 Halloween H2O showed Scream 2 on
a dorm room TV then in 2000 Scream 3 has
a scene where Sydney's mother says
she'll protect her from the boogeyman
which is a name that is interchangeable
with Michael Myers in the Halloween
franchise in Street form Sydney is
introduced as the ultimate scream Queen
Beyond Jamie Lee Curtis the actress who
plays Lori among a variety of other
references so I believe Lori's
transformation into a self-help author
is a reference to the fourth screen her
book is titled stalkers saviors and
Sawan Samhain sowin is the Gaelic
Festival marking the end of the harvest
season in Celtic Ireland which is a big
part of the lore in Halloween 2 3 and 6.
you can watch my episodes on each of
those movies if you want to know more
but the appearance here on Lori's book
title is an Easter egg waiting to be
noticed by fans of The Originals there's
another reference to Celtic folklore in
the song that the homeless man sings
after Corey is thrown off the overpass
you've got to listen pretty carefully to
pick up on it
but
won't stand up
if you couldn't hear that he says
there's a hole in the boat and it won't
stay afloat or Olivia's in the sea This
song is called Olivia's fear Thee the
oil lithius is a mythological sea
serpent creature originating in Irish
mythology the rest of the song may also
be significant
at the end of the movie Michael's hands
are nailed down with knives and his
knees are trapped down by the
refrigerator so this line might be
connected to that but there are still a
ton more Easter eggs referencing other
films in the franchise and I'm going to
talk about how Halloween ends has a
message about covid-19 and what the
director meant when he said that
Haddonfield is going to be dealing with
the pandemic in Halloween ends
there's a four-year Gap in between the
end of Halloween kills and the main
events of Halloween ends during which
Allison graduates gets a job and starts
dating a police officer named Doug
mullaney this character is most likely a
descendant of the Melanie's from the
flashback in Halloween kills that's what
you get with the mullaney's looks like
their family motto got passed down as
well okay
I gotta admit I spent way too long
trying to figure out who the Millennials
were supposed to be in kills and did not
consider that it might be a setup for
the next movie another connection to
kills can be seen right here in the
graffiti which reads love lives today
the same text seen on the donation box
back at mixed bar which helped Inspire
everybody's favorite line from that
middle chapter
but evil dies tonight next to the love
lives today graffiti is just the word
kills in case we forgot the name of the
previous title and there's also some
artwork of Michael Myers which might be
of note because the police procession
goes down the same street before
Michael's execution at the end and
speaking of the ending it also has a
couple of Halloween kills references
after pinning Michael to the kitchen
island Lori shows him his own reflection
in the night probably to test Deputy
Hawkins Theory from the last movie maybe
he wouldn't look it out maybe he was
looking in at his reflection at himself
and when Michael gets the upper hand she
yells do it in a way that almost looks
like she's encouraging him to kill her
of course she's really talking to
Allison who is standing behind Michael
and comes in to rescue her this mirrors
the scene and kills where Allison is at
Michael's mercy and yells do it but
she's really talking to her mother who
is standing at the door with a pitchfork
I find it interesting that in order to
stop Michael Lori pins him down to the
kitchen island because in Halloween 2018
she had a much more elaborate trap for
him under her kitchen island but the
simpler trap ends up being more
effective Halloween 2018 also shares
another similar line with ends at one
point Corey comes over to visit Allison
late at night and he's extremely
flustered she tries to calm him down by
saying look at me the same tactic her
mother once used to try to calm down
Lori during her panic attack at the
Honor Society dinner look at me mom look
at me another 2018 connection is visible
when Allison pulls up at the restaurant
that she's meeting Corey at the sign out
front advertises bonami sandwiches the
same type of Sandwich the cop stationed
outside of Lori's house was raving about
four years prior no upon me sandwich ban
me is essentially just the Vietnamese
version of a French Vega outside of the
40-year trilogy there are still plenty
of other Halloween Easter eggs to
uncover I'll start with Halloween
resurrection and we can work our way
backwards when we first see Michael's
new home in the sewers there's an insert
shot of the rats which brings to mind
Michael's lair in Resurrection where he
lived underneath the house and fed on
rats for sustenance in Halloween H2O
there was a tense scene where the
character Charlie drops a corkscrew into
the garbage disposal and Michael sneaks
up on him as he's reaching in for it
making it seem as if the boogeyman is
going to flip the switch and grind Up
Charlie's hand that doesn't end up
happening but when Michael tries to
force Lori's hand into the garbage
disposal on Halloween ends it's clearly
an homage to that scene there's also a
part where Lori holds on to Michael's
hand after trapping him which reminded
me a lot of the ending of H2O where the
masked man is trapped under the van and
reaches out to Lori where they briefly
touch fingertips this movie also
features a radio host getting massacred
during a broadcast which we saw with
Barry Sims in Halloween 6 a retaliation
from an angry driver of a black
convertible that got scratched which we
saw with Mikey in Halloween 5 and adults
giving a teenager a loaded rifle and
telling him to stay put which we saw
with Sheriff Meeker and Brady in
Halloween 4 and a tow truck being stolen
for a murder Rampage as we saw Michael
do in Halloween 4. as always we get a
ton of connections to the immortal
classic the 1978 original Halloween it
starts when Lori is talking to Hawkins
in the supermarket where you can hear
the grocery store cover of Don't Fear
the Reaper by Blue Oyster Cult
thanks I uh
they must have watched my Chucky season
one video where I ranted about how I
don't dislike the song but it's way
overused in movies and TV because they
proceeded to put it twice in this movie
it also plays over the end credits that
evening when Allison and Corey go to the
dance party Corey bumps into this man
played by Nick Castle the actor under
the Michael Myers mask in the original
and also parts of 2018 and kills this
Easter egg is actually a two-parter
because he opens his jacket and asks
which is the same line Linda had in the
original movie when flashing her tits to
her boyfriend
see anything you like Cory goes off on
his own where he's jumped by a gang of
bullies and tossed from the overpass you
can see Michael Myers in the background
for just a moment before we pan down to
see that Corey is alive Lori first sees
Corey's Behavior start to change when
she notices him peering out from behind
a bush in the front yard this isn't
really a thing you missed because the
shot in the original is so iconic but
people will complain if I don't mention
it a better one to bring up would be
that night when Lori comes home to see
Allison and Corey heading up to the
bedroom through the front window in the
original it was the young Michael Myers
who caught a glimpse of his sister
leading her boyfriend upstairs this is a
continuation of the trend that I talked
about when covering Halloween 2018 and
Halloween kills where we are
increasingly seeing the roles reversed
between Lori and Michael to where she is
becoming the hunter another detail I
discussed in my 2018 video was Allison's
outfit starting to look like the
Wardrobe that Lori wore in the original
and we see that again here in the radio
tower scene where she's wearing that
very familiar blue button up in jeans we
also see Lori wearing pretty much the
same thing in the finale she first knows
that Michael is back when she notices
the open back door which probably
reminded her of the window that he came
through in 78 as she did back then she
hides in a closet where she formulates a
plan of attack the very ending shows an
array of still shots all around Lori's
house it's just like the ending of the
original Halloween but this time with no
ominous breathing sounds I've already
brought up a few details that you might
have missed from Halloween and
soundtrack so here are a couple more the
second song we hear at the dance party
is Halloween by Dead Kennedys whose
lyrics mention a character dressed up
like a clown for Halloween maybe this is
a coincidence but Michael's First
costume in the first movie was a clown
costume and there have been many clown
costume appearances in other Halloween
movies there are a couple other songs
that reflect ideas expressed in the
movie like when Dr Mathis gets home and
puts on the song Tell Me with Your Eyes
by Rob Galbraith eyes are often depicted
in this movie to be indicators of good
or evil Lori says that she can see
Michael in Corey's eyes Roger the father
of the boy who got killed also says when
he looked into Corey's eyes he could
tell that he was down a dark path When
Corey first meets Michael they make eye
contact and something seems to be passed
between them during which we see a
montage that includes a bunch of extreme
close-up of Corey and Michael's eyes
another more overt Music Choice is Burn
it Down by Boy harsher which we hear
when Corey and Allison are riding on the
motorcycle this is a reference to the
conversation they had about their
desires to get away from Haddonfield
after my mom and dad were killed I just
wanted to burn it all to the ground and
get away from Haddonfield they bring up
this phrase a few more times throughout
the rest of the run time whenever
they're talking about skipping town and
this motorcycle scene takes place right
before Corey finally convinces her to
head out with him but what is the deal
with that piano Melody that the
characters keep playing over and over
throughout the film to answer that we'll
have to look back in many years to one
legendary composer
[Music]
we first hear Mr Allen perform cicada
and Fugue in D Minor by Johann Sebastian
Bach in the opening sequence on
Halloween night
[Music]
this music choice makes sense because
the song is most commonly associated
with the classic vampire film Nosferatu
which if you watch things you missed you
already know is where Michael Myers got
his creepy sit-up move from remember how
I talked about Corey's shadow on the
staircase looking like Michael Myers
that also comes from Nosferatu which
helped Inspire many films to this day we
hear these iconic notes repeated
throughout Halloween ends when Alison
first enters the abandoned Allen house
foreign
lets Laurie Strode slip away
and non-diegetically when Michael comes
across Lori and her new house
if you were following updates throughout
the production of Halloween ends you may
remember David Gordon green and talking
about how the time Jump in between
Halloween kills and ends meant that
Halloween ends would take place during
the covid-19 pandemic and in October
2021 interview with uprox he stated and
not only do they have their immediate
World affected by that trauma having
time to process that trauma and that's a
specific and immediate traumatic event
in the community of Haddonfield but then
they also had a worldwide pandemic and
peculiar politics and another million
things that turned their world upside
down this statement made it seem like
the movie was actually going to
acknowledge covid-19 and to be fair it
does acknowledge it despite the virus
breaking out in late 2019 it didn't
begin to affect life in the United
States until 2020. the opening with
Corey and Jeremy took place in October
2019 and then we see a montage of
Anguish during subsequent Halloween as a
side note this Montage contains a really
dark detail we see the mother of Oscar
berlucci one of the victims in 2018
hanging in a devil costume the same
outfit that her son died in almost as if
to suggest that she was overcome with
grief and she decided she could not go
on but we also see this crime seen in a
Jeep or the coroner and crime scene
photographer are both wearing masks
suggesting that this probably happened
in October of 2020 but this is the only
evidence in the movie that the pandemic
began so what did Gordon green mean when
he said that the people of Haddonfield
had their worlds turned upside down by a
worldwide pandemic I don't believe he
ever meant that kovid would be at the
Forefront of the story but rather it
seems to be a big part of the subtext
Laurie's whole character Arc in this
movie is about learning to move on from
a traumatic event she had to deal with
50 some people including her own
daughter getting killed after she tried
to warn everybody about the threats that
was Michael Myers and nobody listened it
sounds a lot like the countless
Healthcare professionals who tried to
sound the alarm about covet 19. nobody
listened 6.5 million people were killed
and that number is still Rising
throughout my Halloween things you
missed series I've talked about how many
Halloween films reflect the culture and
time period that they were made in
Halloween ends is no different there's
never been a more impactful event in our
lifetimes and in this movie Michael
Myers serves as a stand-in instigator
for the collective grief that we've all
been dealing with in fact there are many
instances where Michael is compared to a
virus there are constant worries about
being infected and his evil is literally
referred to as being contagious
[Music]
suffering Michael cost became an
infection passing on to people who never
even thought
contagious right the other kind of
people lives inside us like a sickness
or an infection we even see characters
trying to spin ridiculous narratives
like the idea that Michael was an
innocent mental patient that Laurie
pushed too far causing him to snap by
the time of the movie everybody seems
desperate to blame something for the
hurts that Michael caused did it come
from a bats was it leaked from a lab
does it really matter at this point Lori
is our protagonist and she's trying to
learn to deal with the consequences of
Michael Myers it's all about the
self-promise of hers that she's not
going to let fear rule her life anymore
she still has some safety precautions as
one should but for the first time we see
her trying to get back to normal putting
up Halloween decorations carving
pumpkins and not spending all of her
time preparing to fight she does all of
this despite it being generally accepted
that Michael is still out there and at
times we see her panic and revert back
to the Lorry that we saw in 2018. her
journey in this movie is trying to fully
overcome that that's why I find the
ambiguous ending regarding the fate of
Corey Cunningham to be kind of
interesting near the end of the movie we
see that Corey has the ability to
recover from would be fatal injuries
like Michael does and we never see what
happens to Corey there are many scenes
that imply that evil is part of a
continuous cycle even if you find a way
to defeat Michael Myers there was always
a new evil on the horizon whether it's
Corey or one of the other deplorable
characters in Haddonfield right from the
get-go the opening credits this time
show us a series of Jack lanterns being
born out of other jack-o-lanterns
representing the cycle of evil being
reborn in one scene Lindsay does a tarot
card reading for Allison Oh no I got the
death card no that's not bad on tarot no
that just means a major phase is ending
and a new one is about to begin it seems
to be talking about Allison starting a
new relationship with Corey but in the
grand context of the movie it's talking
about one phase of evil ending with
Michael and a new one beginning in Corey
a similar theme is expressed in Lori's
writing I'm hopeful with perspective
that my experience will help others heal
you have to ask yourself am I in control
or do the elements control me life or
death suicide or cherry blossoms cherry
blossoms in Japanese culture are the
symbolic flower hour of spring a time of
renewal and the fleeting nature of life
we can literally see the cycle repeating
itself in the movie The Old Myers house
is demolished but there just ends up
being a new horror house in Haddonfield
when the Allen house is abandoned after
Jeremy's untimely death but I think
whether we're talking about kovid or
Michael Myers the end of Lori's Memoir
puts it best I've said goodbye to my
Boogeyman but the truth is evil doesn't
die it changes shape and with that I
have analyzed everything you might have
missed in the Halloween franchise except
for the Rob Zombie duology which I
skipped over I think Jimmy champagne and
I will cover those next Halloween the
playlist on the left is my full
collection of episodes on the Halloween
franchise and if you love horror I cover
all kinds of horror here on this channel
make sure you subscribe to cz's World
ring the death battle for all
notifications and I will see you in the
next one assuming we both survive
foreign